Please tell me I'm not the only mom who,
at the end of the night, goes onto Google and starts researching, like,
mom topics.
And sometimes the goal is just to relieve yourself of the guilt. Like,
oh, my god,
am I the worst mom ever in the whole world?
And so you're trying to find other people
that have been in a similar situation,
or you're trying to find research studies.
You're just trying to, like,
make yourself feel better.
In some ways, sometimes you just end up making yourself worse.
But are you with me so far?
One of those nights I went on that little search,
and the rabbit hole I went down brought me to the Stanford University,
and they published an article that said
the teen brain tunes in less to Mom's voice,
more to unfamiliar voices.
And this is what LED me to get a divorce.
This Stanford study. When I read this,
I was like,
if I continue to focus on what type of wife I am
and prioritize my marriage over motherhood,
maybe when they grow up, I'm not even gonna have the opportunity
to have a relationship with them.
Maybe by the time they grow up,
it's too late. The article says around age 13,
kids brains shift from focusing on their mother's voices
to favor new voices. Part of the biological signal
driving teens to separate from their parents.
So it's basically saying, like,
right around the age 13, when Your kids are, like,
entering high school,
and all these new voices and people are gonna come into their life.
That's also when their brain is starting to tune out. Their parents,
um, they literally did brain scans
and published the information in the journal of neuroscience.
So this isn't some, you know,
bunk bullshit. This is real scientific data.
Just as an infant knows to tune into her mother's voice
and adolescent knows to turn into novel voices
as a teen, you don't know you're doing this.
You're just being you.
It goes on to say that in teenage brains,
the reward circuits
and the brain centers that prioritize important stimuli
are more activated by unfamiliar voices
than by those of their mothers.
The brains shift toward new voices is an aspect of healthy maturation.
So it is a good thing. But if you think about it,
you really only have your kids childhood.
So if you spend their whole childhood, um,
like, working on your marriage and focusing on trying to make it work,
you're giving up their whole childhood to some person.
And then to end up still getting divorced, like,
oh, we're just gonna stay together for the kids.
I was like, oh,
hell no. You know,
and maybe that's why some people
end up having such a hard time with their teenagers
is because
in the little bit of time that you had to speak into their life,
you were too busy focused on that
Bullshit ass marriage that wasn't making you happy anyway,
and you ended up divorced anyway.
I rather end if I was gonna end up divorced anyway,
I rather end up divorced and with the ability to still have, like,
some relationship with my kids.